[موسيقى]
هلا مع حالات الشفاء المتكرره اليوم عم
نجد اقبال رائع جدا وهذا اضطرنا ان اليوم
نوسع العياده ننتقل لموقع جديد تلبي
احتياجات هؤلاء الاشخاص
[موسيقى]
هالكلفه البسيطه اليوم متل ما انت جايبه
هم نقول نعم لانه فائده المريض هي المقدمه
لدينا ثم الحاله الماديه اللي هي الكفاف
مثل ما بنقول انه يضل عايش اليوم اذا
رفعتي كلفه الجلسه اولا ستخسري عدد كبير
من الاشخاص اللي ممكن ينتفعوا من هذا
الامر
[موسيقى]
مشروعنا ما هو مشروع فقط علاجي يعني انا
لما اعطي مريض لسعه نحله او مجموعه من
اللسعات انا عم يوصف له عسل
فهي منظومه متكامله
[موسيقى]
هلا ممكن يكون التكلفه العاليه للعلاج
الحالي سبب من الاسباب ممكن يكون وعي
الناس اللي بدهم ينتشر اكثر بسبب السوشيال
ميديا يعني انت اليوم صارت الناس تسمع
اكثر انه فلانه تعالج بشيء طبيعي ما قرب
على الكيماوي واستفاد
[موسيقى]